I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello everybody this is Jenna Fisher. Hi this is Angela Kinsey. And this is our very first Office Ladies podcast. I'm so excited Jenna. I'm so excited I'm a little bit freaking out. I'm freaking out. We hope you guys like it. We have been working really hard. This is a dream
we've had for years of getting to work together again. Yes. Because we became best friends while working on The Office together. We did. We ate lunch together every single day. Every single day. And I think the hardest part for me about the show ending was not getting to see you every day Angela. Me too. It is so special to get to work with your best friend every day. Yes. What a gift. That was the thing you know Steve Carell told us and and I just love this moment so much. He said to Jenna and I no matter what happens with the show this is what you two will take from it. Yeah. And he was so right. It's true. And we've been
trying to figure out some way that we could work together again ever since. So here it is. It's a dream realized. It's a dream realized. We thought what a better time the 15 year anniversary is coming out. And I had like three rubber made bends of photos in my shed and I was going through them and I was getting really nostalgic and I was telling Jenna about it. I was like Jenna we had such an amazing time on that show. I mean it just was one of the joys of my life. And you know I hadn't watched most of the episodes since they aired. So this has been a real treat for me to go back and finally rewatch them. Me too. And it's
so good. You guys. I mean it really. We've become kind of nerdy fans of our own show. We've become nerdy fans. And here's the thing when we were filming it you're kind of living and breathing the day of it. And I watched them all when they aired. But now I'm watching them just as like an audience. Yes. And it's just so fun. It's been so much fun. And I feel like here it is. It's the office bringing us back together again. Yes. It's so special. It's so special. Okay we're geeking out. We're geeking out. And listen you guys we just want you to know we're so excited that you're gonna like join us in this journey and rewatch every week
with us. Listen to us chitty chat about being best friends. And there are gonna be times that maybe we forget something right. Or we miss something. Or we miss something. Because we're not experts we just we're on the show. We're on the show and we love the show. You are actually probably the expert. Yes. You guys are the experts. So please watch along with us send in questions. And let's just rewatch it together. And we're gonna start from the beginning. We're gonna start with the pilot and we're gonna watch it in order. Oh my gosh that brings us to the pilot. This is it. This is it. That's what we're gonna talk about today. Okay so just so
you know how Jenna works you guys. She has like her list. She prints out. She has her laptop. She has two notepads. And then I just bring a whole bunch of colored note cards with a Sharpie. If that sort of paints a picture of how we process information. It is. I am a little bit more I don't know. I don't know Jenna. You're more organized. It's okay. You can say it. And you're more colorful. Oh well okay. Well I guess I'm gonna take that as a compliment. All right so let's get started. Let's get started. We're gonna talk about the pilot. This is season one episode one. This episode is written by Ricky Gervais, Steven Merchant and Greg
Daniels. And directed by Ken Quapas. Let's start with a synopsis. I think that's a good place to start. Great. All right so in this episode we're gonna meet the employees of Dunder Mifflin Paper Company as introduced by their manager Michael Scott. This is just a normal day at an ordinary like workplace. Just people living their lives. Yes. A pilot episode is usually introducing each of the characters and also the convention of the show. And in this case the convention of the show is that this is a documentary. Right. This is the world you're gonna see every day. Is this paper company? Yes. Now I had an idea. What? I
think for each episode we should have something called fast facts. What are you even talking about? This sounds crazy. A fast fact. What is a fast fact? Okay stay with me here. A fast fact is a fact about that episode. Mm-hmm. And then we talk about it. Not necessarily fast. Wait do I have to talk quickly? No. Here's an example of a fast fact. Okay. The show The Office is actually an adaptation of a British show of the same name. The Office. That's right. It was called The Office. It was written by Ricky Dervais and Steven Merchant. It's fantastic. It is amazing. I was a huge fan of it before I even went to the audition for the
American version of The Office. Same. I had watched the entire series and then I got a phone call that they were doing an American version and asking me to audition for the receptionist and I about pooped myself. Yeah. Yes. I was excited and nervous because I loved the British version so much and I was like oh I hope they do it justice and I I mean come on. Years later I think I think we did it. Well we got a lot of critical attention when we were making the pilot and not a lot of love because people really thought we were gonna mess it up. People were worried because this the British show was award-winning critically
acclaimed. It's considered still to this day one of the greatest television comedies ever made. And it deserves all of that. It is. Because it is amazing. Yes. And so there was a lot of pressure on us when we were going in to make this and something that I think is often said is that we did a shot-by-shot remake of the British pilot which is not true. That is not true. It is not a shot for shot remake but we did use their script as a template and there are some adjustments. There are elements though. There are elements that are the same that if you watch it and watch this one. Yes for example in general each of the characters
and like the fact that there's this buffoonish silly boss in their version named David Brent and ours Michael Scott. But if you look at the talking heads there are some differences. Yes and also like the way the story is told is a little different. I mean some of the points are the same. Yes. That happened but it's told differently. But Greg Daniels was the person who was tasked with Americanizing the British show. Yes. And Ricky Gervais and Steven Merchant kind of oversaw that process but they for example they were not on set when we were shooting the pilot. Nope. No they came and they visited with us. I remember
sitting and getting to have lunch with Ricky Gervais. Yeah. Oh my gosh because I was so nervous. Oh yes. I was a super fan of the British version. Me too. And I had been cast in the pilot and they came and they listened to us do a table read and afterwards they asked me, John, Rain, Steve and BJ and Greg to join them for lunch to discuss the show. And I remember thinking if I get fired tomorrow at least I got to have lunch with Ricky Gervais and Steven Merchant. At least that happened. That was to me just huge. Was it a fun lunch? I was not at that lunch. I was not invited. It was so much fun Angela. And I remember Ricky saying something in that
lunch that was really important. He said, you know, in England you can be really, really bad at your job for a long time and you never get fired. He's like, in America that's gonna frustrate people. So my one piece of advice is that Michael can be a buffoon. He can be silly. He can be irritating. But you should, I suggest, he said that you show glimpses of him actually being a good salesperson. And we do that throughout the show. You see in future episodes that he is actually good at sales. And he said that's gonna be an important, I think, piece of the puzzle. And Steven Merchant said, my piece of advice would be to lean a little bit more
into the Jim and Pam relationship. He said, he knew the heart of it. He said, that's really gonna be the heart of your show. Because the British version, they did six episodes for their first season, six episodes for their second season, and one big Christmas special. And they knew that for American television, we were looking to do years and we ended up doing 200. So he said, you need to keep the heart beating on the show. And so that's the heart of the show. That's Jim and Pam. Okay, I have another fast fact. We filmed the pilot six months before the rest of season one. And we shot it on the second floor of a real office building
in Culver City. So it was an actual office building. And a lot of times on sets, they build the office. So if they want to film and get a certain camera angle, they can move a wall. They can move a window. They can move a door because they built it. They actually say wall flying out and they move a whole wall. They move a whole wall. It's insane. On our show, because it was in an actual office building, you just had to work with it. And it sort of really lended itself to the documentary style that all the shots weren't gonna look pretty. They weren't gonna be lined up just right because they had to work around actual walls and
windows. They couldn't just pop them out. I remember speaking to Ken Quapas, our director, about setting certain rules for the documentary style of filming. And he said it was very important to him that for all of the actors and the crew that the set felt like a real working office and a real documentary was happening. And so one of the rules that he came up with was that he cleared the entire set of all crew members except for a camera operator, a boom operator, and himself. Yes. And that was it. That was it. He also made all of the actors come in every morning, go through hair and makeup, and then sit at our desks starting at 7.30
a.m. and we had to pretend to work. Yes. And he walked around with the documentary crew and filmed us for 30 minutes. Yeah, just us quietly working. And little shots that you see, for example, of Pam doing whiteout, that is a piece of B-roll from one of those working mornings that we did. And we did that every day on the pilot. Something else about this episode that I noticed is that there is a random exterior shot of a building. Oh, Jenna, let me tell you. Well, wait, wait, let me grab one of my colorful note cards, as you call them. Exterior shot at 9.29, 9 minutes and 29 seconds. Not our building. With a huge exclamation
point. This is a big discovery. This is a big discovery for me. Not only not our building, it wasn't the building we were filming in. I don't know where they got that shot. It's like stock footage from something. I think it was stock footage. And then you never, we never use it again. That was it. That was it. They should go back and take that out. See you later. And put a shot of the reels under Mifflin exterior. Jenna's getting sassy on you. Yeah, I'm gonna call someone. Someone get it right. All right. Here is my last fast fact. Okay, lady. This episode. Okay. Meredith is not Meredith. She is not. She is Henriette. It's Henriette. Yes. Meredith
is played by Henriette Mantell in the pilot episode, not Kate Flannery. This is true. Henriette Mantell was a comedy actress who had just broken out because she had played Alice in the Brady Bunch films. And she was there for the pilot. And then it was six months later that we got picked up and then we started filming the rest of the episodes. And I guess the rumor was she was not available. She was busy. And we had to recast her. And so Kate Flannery came in. Here is my fast fact. Kate Flannery and I met years before the office. We were in a all-female improv group called Bitch Planet. Wahoo! Sunday nights at like 10 p.m. That's when
you want to... It's exactly when you want your comedy. That's when you want to watch improv. Kate and I had known each other for a really long time. And also Oscar Nunez and I did a sketch comedy show together called Hot Towel. Where do you get these names, Angela? So it was really fun for me because here I am. Like, I was so nervous the first day. I didn't know Oscar had been cast. He didn't know I had been cast. You guys, this was sort of before, this was before smartphones. Like, it's not like you like texted someone you got a role or you put it on your social media. There was none of that. So you walked in and were completely
surprised. Completely surprised when I saw Oscar. Not only did I see Oscar, but Ken Coapa sat us next to each other. So I was like, oh my god, I'm gonna be okay. That's amazing. My buddy's here. And then Brian walked in as Kevin. I was like, here we go. We're off to the races. You guys were amazing in accounting. Thank you. Thank you so much. I'm giving you a compliment. Thank you so much. So yeah, so I was so excited to have these friends that I had performed with for years before the office sitting in my little corner back there. I remember meeting everyone for the first time. Do you remember your first impressions of people? I remember my
first impression of Rainn Wilson. Tell me. Well, I met Rainn Wilson at a live test audition. So for all the leads of the show, they brought us into screen test and they mixed and matched us. There were four Pam's and four Dwight's and four Jim's and four Michaels. Yeah. And we spent an entire day being mixed and matched with each other. And I remember I met Rainn Wilson and he was in character, but I couldn't really know that because I didn't know Rainn yet. And I thought he was the weirdest person I'd ever met in my life. Wait, he was in character the whole time? Yeah. He just was Dwight. Oh, so method Rainn. He had his hair like that.
Oh, so method. But you know what? I kind of did the same thing. I did my Pam hairstyle. The hairstyle that I wore on the show, I sort of invented through the audition process that sort of half up, half down, scrunchy, air-dried curl. And so I was very quiet. I didn't talk to people in the waiting room because I just thought Pam was sort of not a chatter and I didn't want to get out of character. I remember one of the first things. This is so random, but it's true. That first week of filming Rainn's wife came to have lunch and this is the the main interaction I remember from Rainn during the pilot episode. Rainn introduced
me to his wife. She was pregnant at the time with their son. Yes. And he said, this is my wife Holly, bearer of my seed. And I was like, what? And she started laughing. But that was just Rainn being Rainn. That's Rainn. That is Rainn, but wouldn't Dwight say that? He would also say that. This is Angela, bearer of my seed. Yes. She's carrying my seed. I'm like, oh my god. I feel like we all had little parts of our characters in us. But I don't know if that's true of you because you are so opposite from Angela Martin. I am. I was thinking about how you were saying, like, you stayed in character and so did Rainn in between your auditions in the
lobby. I would not have. I would have been like, chitty chat chat. And then I would have just turned into a bitch when I entered the room. Well, you know, I didn't have any scenes with Rainn in the pilot of substance. I didn't have any one-on-one scenes. So for me, when we were shooting the pilot, the people that I really bonded with were Steve, John, and you because you were over the little part. You were my closest seatmate in the office. So you and I bonded. And I remember after we finished the pilot and we all left and we didn't know if we were going to be picked up or make any more. Shortly after that, I turned 30
years old. It was a big milestone birthday for me. And I really wondered if I should invite any of you guys. And I didn't. I didn't invite you guys because I thought, well, I'm probably never going to see them again. Should I throw you another 30th birthday party and invite everyone? Would you? And then we could just say happy 30th. Will you? Okay. Because now you guys are some of my closest friends and you aren't at my milestone birthday. Okay, we have to throw you a 30th birthday party. It won't be weird. All right, guys. So next up, we are going to break down this episode. We're going to really get into the nitty
gritty. We're going to talk about scenes and memories and stories. So stick with us. All right, and we're back. We're talking about the pilot episode of the office. And I think we should talk about some of our favorite moments, Jenna. Yes. Well, one of my favorite moments is the dynamic between Pam and Michael. I mean, selfishly, I guess I'm in that moment. But I really loved working with Steve Carell. I really loved how much he let me be silent and just look at him and just react. Yes, I loved that. But I especially love whenever Malora Hardin, who plays Jan Levinson Gould, got in the mix. She's so commanding. Just like Malora's
presence is like, I'm scared of her. Yes. I get it. I get why he was a little scared of her. And I love the scene where Michael tries to throw Pam under the bus about why he doesn't have the agenda that he's supposed to have. And it's because he told her to throw it in the receptacle, the trash can that is a special filing cabinet for corporate memos. And I remember shooting that scene. And I just remember every time that Pam said, you told me to put it in a special filing cabinet that is a trash can that we would giggle. And so I just remember the matter of factness of that moment and how fun that was. Pam totally stood up
for herself in her own little way in that moment. Here's the thing about Steve Krell. He is one of the nicest people you will ever meet. He is so nice. I know it's almost even become like a joke, like Steve Krell's the nicest person ever, but he is. I know. And people ask me a lot, what's it like to work with Steve Krell? Are you just laughing all the time? And no, you're not laughing all the time because Steve isn't on all the time. He's not one of those. He's a real person. He's a real person. And he's, I've worked with comedians who are on all the time. You walk around and you can just, they can't turn off their joke making brain.
I drive my car, sorry. It's a little insane. Steve is not like that. You and Steve and I would sit and have long conversations about the best frozen yogurt in the San Fernando Valley. Oh, I will never forget the morning. On Monday mornings, Steve would come out of his office, out of Michael Scott's office between scenes. He would walk over to Jenna and I and we would talk about our weekends. And one Monday morning he walked over and he was like, ladies, guess what I did this weekend? We're like, what? And he goes, I went to Target. He would talk to us about Target. And he told us about his Target run. It was really,
really sweet. You know, recently I was in a Michaels purchasing some supplies for a crafting job. And the checkout guy said, Oh my gosh, now this is getting crazy. This morning, Oscar Nunez came in here. Then Steve Carell and now you, what do you guys all live here? We love crafting. We love crafting. We're all here. We're all sort of, I guess we all live around this one Michaels crafting store. Yeah. I texted Steve and I said, Steve, the checkout guy at Michaels told me you were buying some crafting supplies today. And he said, Oh, yes, I needed some glue sticks. He told me what he needed. He's like, what were you
there for? But that is Steve. That is Steve. That's the kind of stuff we would talk to him about. And so to then, to have that man then shift into this scene where he's just being awful to my character, like throwing you under the bus in front of the big boss lady. Yes. When our real dynamic was just like so much, so much love. So in the scene, Jan tells Michael, there's going to be downsizing. Yeah. This is big news. This is important. Michael should be paying attention. We've already established that he's thrown away the agenda for the meeting. Yeah, he should take this seriously. But instead, he takes a phone
call from his friend, Todd Packer. Todd Packer, his party buddy. He clearly covets. He thinks this guy's amazing. Another interesting fact about this scene is that the voice of Todd Packer that comes on the phone is not the voice of the real Todd Packer. What are you talking about? Dave Kekner ends up playing Todd Packer. When we meet him in season two, this role is played by Dave Kekner. But Dave was not hired when we shot the pilot. What? He's not. Wait, so I was think it sounds like Dave Kekner. Who is it? But I'm thinking it can't be Dave Kekner, right? It's all this time. I thought it was Dave Kekner.
It's not Dave. Who is it? I texted Dave Rogers, our editor. Dave Rogers. Knower of all things. I mean, he is knower of all office facts. He is. Okay. What did Dave say? Dave said that the voice is played by Toby Huss. Toby Huss. Yes. Very famous voice actor. He was king of the hill for years. And friends of Greg Daniels. Yes. Toby Huss is so talented. I know. How about that? That is Todd Packer's voice in the pilot episode. Yes. Well, I loved. Here's one of the things I loved about the pilot and just sort of the brilliance that was Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant and Greg Daniels and their collaboration building this world
out is that so many like truths about the characters were established in all these subtle ways. And one of the things I loved is that Michael is clearly thrilled that the camera people are there. Oh, he is so excited. He could not have signed up for this faster. I mean, he jumped at the chance at this. And he thinks he is one of the world's best comedians. Oh, yeah. In the world. He is one of the funniest people in the world. He has that amazing talking head where he talks about who his heroes are. Yes. And they are Bob Hope, Abraham Lincoln, Bono, and God probably. He said probably God. And here's a little tidbit. Steve
wrote that. He did. Yes. Oh my God. I love that. I didn't know that. Yeah. Greg asked him, would you mind writing a list of who you believe are Michael Scott's heroes? Oh, so brilliant. Bob Hope. And it made it in. Yes. Well, and he just every chance he gets, he's like looking to the camera and doing his comedy bits. And this sort of sets up just Michael's love of being liked and being appreciated. And he wants everyone to think he's like the fun boss. And he, he thinks he's legitimately talented. Well, there's that scene where he does the $6 million man where he's walking away from Pam's desk. Yes. I could not get through that scene. And in
fact, in order to get my reaction shot, they had to make Steve leave the set because I couldn't get through it. So that react. Yes. That reaction of me was not while Steve was actually doing anything because every time he did it, I started laughing. Yeah. Well, he's so giddy to do his $6 million man. I timed it because as I watched it, I was like, wow, this is a long time to commit to this bit because he's like, he did it. It started at nine minutes, 40 seconds. And he, it doesn't end until 10 minutes, two seconds. Oh my gosh. That is 22 seconds of the slow mo bit. I think that's why that's a ton. When you think
of like the whole scope of an episode for 22 seconds, you went, I mean, that's probably why I couldn't get through it. That's why they couldn't get a reaction of me because I couldn't hold it for 20 seconds. I couldn't hold a straight face that long. And he was so desperate for you to look at him and have some kind of reaction. Oh man. Okay. What else? What else? There's the conference room scene. Oh, yes. Where Michael officially announces that there is going to be downsizing at Dunder Mifflin. This is a big theme of the pilot. This is the news that Jan gives him when she comes into the office that Dunder Mifflin can no
longer support both a Scranton branch and a Stanford branch and that they're going to have to prove who is the branch that should stay. But even if Scranton gets to stay, there might be downsizing of employees. Yeah. The company's hurting and they have to make some cutbacks and they have to fire some people. Yes. And so Michael goes into the conference room and this is the first time we see Michael in the conference room. And of course Dwight won't give him the space to do that. It's their first power struggle, which you'll see for years to come. It's the first time he refers to himself as the assistant
regional manager. Yeah. Which is great. And I noticed something about this conference room scene. What? I bet I have it on my note card. I bet you have it that there are some extras in this scene that are never to be seen again. There are two women. Do you want me to refer to it? Let me just tell you what I wrote on my note card. Okay. Conference room faces. Simicolon. So in the background, there are two women and they are the real production company accountants for our show. Yes. We needed more people to fill out the space and they pulled in our actual accountants from our production office. Yes. Ken Guapas, the
director, walked into the production office and asked if anyone would like to be in the background of a scene. And those two women came and sat there for that couple of hours. They were so giddy. They loved it. They loved it. They loved it. And then also in the conference room, some faces you might see sprinkled through the first season, but then they don't go past that season are Luanne Kelly, who worked in the Annex. Yes. She is someone that you see a lot. I get asked a lot. Who is the lady in the Annex? Yes. She was sort of over where Mindy ends up sitting. Yes. By Kelly's desk. And then also, of course, Devon
and Creed, who ultimately do have a storyline that will come later. Not until season two. That's right. So for an entire season, you just see Devon and Creed in the background of scenes. They don't get any lines until the second season. But that is the only scene our actual accountants are in because then they had to go back to work. They did. They had to actually go back to being accountants for the show. I think this is an interesting tidbit. Phyllis Smith, who plays Phyllis on the show, she was the casting associate for the office. So when I auditioned for the office, she read my audition scenes with me.
Everyone. I read my scene with Phyllis. That's who I read my scene with. Yes. And Ken Quapas, the director, was so taken with how she did her readings with the actors. She's so earnest, you guys. She is so earnest. And so real that he said to Greg Daniels, I want her on the show. Can I give her a part on the show? And so Phyllis went from being a casting associate, which she had done for years with Alison Jones, the casting director, worked with Phyllis to having a part on this pilot. And I think because we all thought the show was going nowhere, it was fine. And after the pilot was over, she went back to being a casting
associate. She went right back to work. Phyllis has a great story that she tells it. The way she found out that she got Phyllis is that she got sides and they said Phyllis. So there was a character and they named it Phyllis. And Ken was like, that's you. You're Phyllis. And she was like, what? We wrote a part for you based on the numerous readings with actors. You're now in the show Phyllis. Which is just so cool because Phyllis had wanted to be an actress. She had been an actress. She had been a burlesque dancer. No one can shimmy. No one can shimmy like Phyllis. Like she has a great shimmy. She had an amazing photo on her desk because Ken
Quapas wanted us to personalize our desk for the pilot episode and moving forward. So we all brought in something from home. I have a photo of myself and my grandmother in a frame that says, I heart grandma. And my eyes are closed in the photo, but my grandmother framed it anyway. And so I have that on my desk and it just kind of like tickled me and made me think of my grandmother. I had a picture of me and my sister swimming in Lake of the Ozarks. Yes. And Phyllis had a picture of herself in her full burlesque outfit with a red feather boa draped over her shoulders. Angela, let's take a quick break. Okay, Jenna. You gonna get a
snack? Why? Because you always get a snack during the breaks. I do. So then we get to that crazy scene where Michael is walking Ryan the temp around. So he's just been told that we need downsizing. And then he hires a temp. He hires some. The opposite of downsizing. Can I just say one thing I love too is when Dwight has his talking head and he said, I've been talking about downsizing for years. I brought it up in my interview. Like who does that? Who's like interviewing for a job and is like, you should downsize. I would like this job. I suggest you get rid of three other people. So here's a little fun fact. It's not a fast fact, but
a fun fact is that BJ Novak was the first person cast on the show. He was? He was. Greg Daniel saw him doing stand up comedy and he thought he was like this guy. I want this guy. And so he offered BJ a role as both a writer and the role of Ryan the temp on the show. So when I came in for my audition, BJ was already cast. He was the very first person. And he was also the first example of that synergy of having people who were both performers and writers for the show, which was so great. Something that we haven't talked about, but we will talk about it many times as the show goes, is that what a wonderful creative
collaboration we had between the writers and the actors. And that was because of Greg Daniels. He sort of set the tone that he wanted this creative collaboration. He wanted to hear our ideas and he wanted writers on the set. And I think we were just so much the better for it. I've been on other shows now that where the writers and the actors are separate and there's not a lot of collaboration. And it feels weird after having experienced something else. No, Greg really trusted us to be the experts of our characters. So whenever he was trying to mull something over or justify something, he would come to us
and ask us just in the way that he went to Steve and said, Hey, do you have any thoughts on who Michael Scott's heroes would be? Yeah. He trusted us to have done our homework and know our character so well that we could contribute. Yeah, it was great. It was really special. So also in that scene, that is the famous stapler in Jell-O. Yaw. The stapler goes in Jell-O. Yaw. I have seen so many people recreate this. How? How? I am blown away. Every time I see a fan tag me in a photo where they put something in Jell-O, I'm like, I'm very impressed. Where to go? I know. Something we haven't mentioned is the flirtation between Jim and Pam in this
episode. And it goes on through the whole first two-thirds of this episode or three-quarters of this episode. Little, little things. What did I write on my pink note card, Jenna? Mixed berries. And quotes. He's on to me. Yeah. That is one of the cutest things. It is so pure. It is. Like that's, that's flirting for them. That he knows your favorite yogurt. But up until the end, you are just sort of following this flirtation between the two characters and then all of a sudden Roy walks in the door. David Dinman. Carrying that weird trash bag. We never know what's in that trash bag. What is he carrying? I loved it so much when, when
John is Jim is like, what's in the bag? And Roy's like, yeah, just tell her. Yeah, tell her I'll meet her in the car. Yeah. But I think it is such a, I remember watching the pilot with people and having them be shocked. Yeah. Like, oh wait. Oh crap. She's been engaged three years. Three years to this guy. Holy moly. Yeah. And then Jim has that heartbreaking talking head. Do I think I'll be invited to the wedding? Oh, Jim. Breaking hearts. He's breaking hearts. Right out of the gate. He's breaking hearts. He really is. So another really cute, flirty moment between Jim and Pam. After the conference room scene where we all find out there's
going to be downsizing. The camera cuts to different groups of people talking about downsizing. But when it cuts to Jim and Pam, we are not talking about downsizing. Who are you guys talking about? We are talking about your cat party. Do you remember this? I do. I do. So this is, I feel like this is really significant and kind of goes on the heels of what we were talking about with Greg wanting to collaborate with actors. So Ken said, listen, I'm just going to roll the camera. You two just talk to each other. Don't push it. Just talk. Make each other laugh. And so here's something you should know is that earlier in the scene, Ken had
asked me if I would pass out papers in the background. Yeah. I only had three lines in the episode. They were, you know, otherwise I was just background, basically, for that, you know, pilot. So he asked me if I would pass out papers. And I had just doodled a little drawing of a cat and I said, you're invited to Sprinkle's birthday party. I just sort of made up that my character had found a cat in the parking lot. I don't know. I was just sort of bored and we all made up backstories. Yeah. I just, I just made up backstory that my character had found this cat in the parking lot. But I think it's really significant because you, in your
character, actory prep work, decided that your character was a crazy cat lady. I guess I did. Because you kind of decorated your desk with the cat stuff. Now, the prop department that set my desk had a paper clip holder that was a cat laying on its side and it holds paper clips. Okay. I took it from my desk. I still have it. I might have stolen it as a memento. And so I think I was just looking at that and I was doodling and truth be told, there's only about three things I can draw in real life that look like the actual thing. And one of them is a cat. One of them is a cat. That's kind of true for me. I can draw a palm tree. I can
draw a cat. And I can draw a Snoopy. Hey. There you go. And I guess I had just doodled a cat. And so I'd written on, so maybe my poor, like my poor skills at drawing is also what gave birth to this moment. But I drew this cat and I wrote you're invited to Sprinkle's birthday party in the parking lot. And you gave it to me. I handed it to you earlier. And it was weird. I remember getting it in the background of the scene and thinking, I don't know what this is, but I stuck it to my computer monitor. Yeah, it was on a post-it and you stuck it to your computer. So when Ken Kuop has asked me to talk to John about anything to do this
scene, just talk to each other, I noticed that post-it note. And I said, are you going to go something like, I can't remember the cat party on Sunday? And he he's like, oh, no, it's ridiculous. No, definitely not. And then we giggle. And that is the bit that they left in the episode. And that's the birth of Sprinkles. That was the birth of Sprinkles. That turned into this cat birthday party. Greg honed in on that. He was like, what is the cat birthday party? And I said, well, Angela gave me this post-it note about her birthday party for her cat or something. And he loved it. And then for four seasons, we
discussed Sprinkles until his untimely death. Oh, okay. Yes. That's another episode. I won't make you think about it. Because it's one of my favorite Michael moments too. Yeah. So that was really fun how just these little elements of us in the background sort of being bored and improvising made it into the show. Yeah. It's so special to me. All right. So I have something that I am so curious about. And Jenna, I don't even know if you know this. Fans out there, I don't know if you know it or if we need a text. Dave Rogers, our editor extraordinaire. So my Dwayne Angela fans, did you notice in the pilot episode that Dwight is singing
Little Drummer Boy as he unpacks his desk? Angela. He's singing like, come they told me. And then in season three, I karaoke Little Drummer Boy and Dwight joins in and sings with me. Now, that story is that I was very nervous to sing. I don't like singing in front of people. And and rain as Dwight just jumped in and kind of like supported me. So I wasn't up there alone. And he kneeled down and he held the microphone for me. And I'm just like, Oh my God. I mean, what? That's weird. Crazy. I feel like that has to be a coincidence. I think it's a coincidence. But how and so many fans say to me, like, what amazing synergy it is
that Dwight is singing Little Drummer Boy in the pilot. And then in season three, I sing it to him. Now, did a writer remember that? Was that something that like was or was that just in the subconscious of the show? I don't know. I don't know. You know what I found? I found this article. And I can't remember where I apologize. I found an article that was all about secret messages in the pilot episode. And one of the secret messages that someone points out is that in the scene where Roy comes in the door for the first time, the boom mic dips into frame and someone wondered, was that a nod to the boom operator Brian that
we will meet in season nine? No, that was just an accident. Was it was it foreshadowing to let us know that there are three men in Pam's life, Jim, Roy, and Brian? No, no, that was just a boom operator accident. And they left it in because it's a documentary. Yes, we left that stuff in all the time. That was a thing that we we coveted that. We loved it. If someone, if the camera person fumbled or if the boom accidentally was in shot, we still used it and we could. And that was actually great because sometimes you're on a set and your best take is ruined because of some, you know, technical technical accident on the
set, but we were able to use all of it. We didn't have to put it on the cutting floor. Okay, so yeah, so no conspiracy. But yeah, I don't know if Dwight singing Little Drummer Boy and the pilot and Angela singing it in Benihana Christmas in season three is just a crazy coincidence, but it's cool, right? It's a pretty cool observation. It's pretty cool. I actually really love these fan theories because I like to think that these accidents or coincidences, if they are accidents, are part of a fun collective unconscious thing that kind of lend itself to the magic of the show. Wow, Jenna, that was really deep. It
kind of was. I got real philosophical there. Oh my gosh, I feel like I just had like a vision of what you were like in college or something. Yeah. Like you sat around like maybe like you wore like black turtlenecks and like, I don't know, I was kind of like, I was kind of like Art Show Pam. Art Show Pam. With my turtleneck. Yeah. My jumper. Well, I like it. Spilling philosophy. All right, Angela, what have you got for us? I only had one speaking scene in the pilot and so did Brian. It was back in accounting when Angela and Kevin are trying to figure out who's going to be fired for downsizing. We were really nervous about shooting the
scene. It's the only time we speak. And it was at the end of the day, Ken Cuapas, who's, you know, we've said the nicest guy was like, go ahead. And I said, um, somebody's going to be fired. It'll probably be me. And Brian, as Kevin says, yeah, it'll probably be you. And Ken came up to me and goes, Hey, um, Angela, can you do it again? And like, just give it like half, give it half. Hmm. So I guess I was like, was I too big? Was I like, somebody's going to be fired. It'll probably be me. Like, and then so I was like, somebody will probably be fired. It'll probably be me. Someone's going to get fired. Is that the exact line?
Somebody's going to be fired. It'll probably be me. Then he came up and he goes, half of that. I said, Oh, okay. So then I was like, somebody's going to be fired. It'll probably be me. And he goes, half of that. Oh, I said, Oh my god, I'm going to get fired because I'm like an improv sketch comedy actor and clearly I'm too broad. And so ultimately the take they use by the end of it, I literally was like, somebody's going to be fired. It'll probably be me. And then Brian's like, yeah, I'll probably be you. And Ken was like, we got it. I was like, do you want to point out what you noticed about this scene as well? Yes. Kevin, here's
my tidbit, guys, is that when I watch this and Brian, I want to call you about it. You just sound like Brian to me. You don't sound like the Kevin voice. Okay, can we play it? I bet it's going to be me. Probably going to be me. Yeah, it'll be you. Oh my gosh. That's Brian. That is Brian's voice. That's not because Kevin would have been like, yeah, it'll probably be me. Yeah, that's a horrible Kevin. We just really did not do that. Oh my gosh, I want to call Brian about it. But when I watched it, I was like, wait a second. Like that's Brian. But I think in the pilot, we are still sort of like figuring out our characters and who they
were. However, I have to say, Angela. What? I went into the deleted scenes. Oh my God. On the DVD, season one DVD. And there is, this is something we did on the pilot. Some of it was an acting exercise where they called us each into the conference room separately and they just asked us unscripted lines about our characters and about our relationship to other characters. I remember this. It wasn't written. It was not written. We just improvised. So this was sort of, I think, an exercise that Ken wanted to do, that Greg and Ken came up with. In addition to that thing where they filmed us all just working, they also filmed us
being interviewed in character. And I think Greg thought, this will be great. Maybe I could use some of these little tidbits here and there. Well, there is a series of interviews with each of the members of accounting. Oh my God. Where you guys are all trash talking each other very subtly. And Angela, you have this incredible deleted scene talking head where they ask you about Oscar. Is this where I compare him to a stapler? Yes. Sam, can you pull that up so we can listen to that? Oscar, how do I describe him? He's like a stapler. Do I need a stapler? Yes. But I'm still the one that has to push it down. I did. I improvised that
because I was trying to think of like what, like, how does Angela see Oscar? And he's just like, he's necessary, but he's a, he ends up being more work for her. Yes. He's annoying. What was so clear to me when I was watching them was this accounting dynamic had already started. Yeah. This little pod that you guys formed, this little trio, it was there from the very beginning. Also, I do have to point fans, all of the deleted scenes are fantastic. Rainn Wilson has some talking heads. There is a long extended deleted scene talking head of him talking to Ken Quapas, who played the documentarian for us. He would ask us the questions,
our director, all about where the boom microphone was. Rainn as Dwight was very distracted by the boom. Oh my God. And he was saying, I really need you to move that. Ken says, we can put it in your blind spot. And he says something like, I don't have a blind spot. I've been trained. So it's especially distracting for me. You need to understand that I'm highly trained. And it's just this little like non-presentational conversation between Dwight and the documentarian about how to be mic'd. I just want to say one thing. So many great things that were established in the pilot that you go on to see for years to come. Of course, one
of the big ones is the gym versus Dwight, like sort of their battle, right? And the pranks that Jim is going to do on Dwight. And I love that it just started out so simply with Dwight pushing all of Jim's papers back to his desk and then Jim making the pencil wall. That is just ridiculous. Like, well, that was borrowed from the British show. In the British show, they have the same desk war, but instead the gym character piles up a bunch of boxes. He makes a box wall between the desks. And we did that when we filmed the pilot. We had Jim make a box wall. And in fact, you can see it in the background of conference room scenes. You
can see a bunch of boxes piled up on Jim's desk. My lady, I'm going to go back and look. Later, when we got picked up, we reshot that scene and turned it into a little pencil thing. And you can also see that rain's hair is a little bit different in the pencil scene compared to the rest of the pilot. It's not as poofy. That's right. Yeah, exactly. Rain as Dwight went through poofy hair phase, which looks like they used a little miniature like rolling brush to blow dry his hair. And then he went through flat parted down the middle phase. Well, rain created the hairstyle for Dwight. And he said before that it is
based on the hairstyle that he wore when he was a 16-year-old boy. And so he did his own hair for the pilot. That makes me laugh. I've seen those photos of rain. They're crazy. You wore your own clothes in the pilot. I wore my own clothes in the pilot. All right. So the last sort of thing I think we need to talk about is this big prank on Pam, quote-unquote, the scene where Michael fake fires her. Well, he's so excited because Jim has had a very successful prank. And Michael just, he wants to be in the spotlight. He wants to be the funny guy. So he's going to show off for Ryan the Temp and he's going to fake fire Pam.
And it of course goes horribly wrong and she ends up in tears. And we shot that scene probably 30 times. Wow. And at the beginning of the scene, you can see everyone in the background kind of getting ready to leave for the day. And all those people had to wait for hours. They would have to start in the background and then we would do this whole scene. Oh, I know, Jenna. I know. I was there. I had to grab my jacket, my coat and my purse, put them down, my coat and my purse. I think of any scene in the entire history of the office, this is the one that I've done the most because we did about 30 takes of it that day. But it was also my audition scene.
This was one of my audition scenes. And so I auditioned for months for this role. I did that scene one time when I auditioned for the role of Pam and I didn't get it. This is such a crazy, crazy bit of trivia. Yes, yes. Your first audition for the office was for the role of Pam. Was for the role of Pam and I wore a pink sweater. What? We both had the same instinct. I wore a pink sweater and my hair down and I was told to look, you know, like not too fancy. So I didn't do too much with my hair and makeup and I went in and I did the scene
and it was for a roomful people, the producers. And when we got to the point where Michael fake fires you and you start to cry and you call him a jerk. Yeah. When I called him a jerk, everyone started to laugh. And I thought, I did something wrong. I don't think they're supposed to laugh at this moment. And of course, like, Jenna, you were so brilliant because you brought such a vulnerability to Pam that even though this job sucks and she hates it, she needs it. She needs this crappy job. Yeah. And you really felt her in that moment. You just, my heart broke for her.
And when you call him a jerk, it's just like you're really wounded and it checks Michael in his place of like, that wasn't cool. Well, it's funny because this was a somewhat controversial scene about whether or not it should be included. When Ricky and Steven were counseling Greg, I understand that they told him that he should consider cutting the scene because they said that it's in their pilot and they felt like they always had to fight to come back from it, that it made the boss a little too mean and not, and so later they really leaned into his buffoonery. But Greg fought to keep it in. He thought, no, we're going to, we're going to try it.
We're going to let her cry. We're going to let Michael be mean to her. Now, there was an alt line where I think that sometimes instead of saying, you're a jerk, I said, you're a sad little man. And they said, that's too, that's too harsh. You can't come back from that. That is harsh. So here's a little, a little fun tidbit, Jenna. Another tidbit, not a fast fact. A tidbit from Angela Kinsey. When Michael wants to prank Pam in front of Ryan the Temp, Michael as Steve turns to Ryan, BJ, and says, have you ever seen, you know, do you like prank
shows? Have you ever seen punked? BJ was on punk. He was on. He was on season two of punk. So I thought that was a nice little nod that he's looking at someone who was on punked and says, do you like punked? And BJ's like, yeah, like as Ryan. Anyway, that's a Kinsey tidbit for you. So the end of this episode, Pam is been crying and Jim wants to cheer her up. So he puts Michael's world's best boss mug in Jell-O. Now, this was exclusive to our show. So the whole It's not in the BBC version. That's right. The mug itself is set up in an early talking head. And then this convention of ending the episode with Jim doing something sweet for Pam by putting the mug in Jell-O. That was all Greg Daniels idea. And I think it's such a sweet way to end the show.
Yeah. And that's the last shot. Oh my God, Jenna. That's it. We just did it. We did it. We did it. We did our first podcast. You guys, we really, we were really nervous. We actually in the middle of doing this, I was getting so nervous that Angela, that Angela made us turn off the microphones and have a dance party to loosen me up. I did. I put on Taylor Swift's paper rings and I made her dance around and get out of her head. I was spiraling. You were. But here's the thing. This is why we're nervous is because the show means so much to us. And we are new, obviously, to the podcast scene and your support has been overwhelming. I literally teared up when we let you guys know we were doing a podcast and just the immediate support from all of you out there. I got a little
emotional. Me too. So I just thank you guys so much and just know how much it means to us that this show that is so special to us keeps finding an audience. It just really means the world to us. It's changed our lives forever. Yeah. Yeah. So thank you. Thank you guys. All right. First one. First one. Send in questions. Yeah. You can send us questions at officeladiesatearwolf.com. If you have any questions about an episode, put that episode title in the subject line and we will, we'll read them all. We'll read them all. And then they also said if you want to leave us a voice memo, we could actually play you asking your question in the podcast, which would be kind of cool. Which would be kind of cool. Yes. All right. You can also find us at officeladiespod
on Instagram and Twitter. Yeah. We're setting those up. And we're going to have a website called officeladies.com and you can find out everything about what we're doing with the podcast. That's a lot of ways to find us. That is. Is it too many? Maybe. I don't know. I'm gonna be like, we get it. We get it. Next week, since we're going in order, we're going to be talking about diversity day. So much fun. So if you want to watch it with us, just watch diversity day by next Wednesday and then we'll talk about it. Yeah. And do you hear that? That's our theme music by my neighbor, Creed Bratton. It's his song, Rubber Tree, with Mr. Ed Helms on Banjo. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is
produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. Remember, you can listen to ad-free versions of Office Ladies on Stitcher Premium. For a free month of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.